este estribo transgénico hb4 tiene mayor
tolerancia a la sequía lo que puede ser
clave en un contexto de persistente
falta de lluvias la última lluvia en
esta zona
lluvia lluvia considerable fue el 25 de
mayo con 30 milímetros y después nada
más O sea que este Trío se está haciendo
prácticamente sin agua el trigo
transgénico está siendo probado en lotes
como este y para llegar a este punto
pasaron años de investigación y
desarrollo estas todas son plantas de
arabiadopsis se está la planta modelo
donde inicialmente pusimos el gh M4
Raquel Chan es la persona que lideró el
trabajo en el que se incorporó un gen de
girasol al trigo que es lo que le otorga
la tolerancia a la sequía el lugar donde
les mejoraría muchísimo muchísimo la
producción por eso lo están pidiendo lo
están aprobando tampoco es la salvación
del mundo y eso también tiene que quedar
claro o sea no es que esto va a salvar
el hambre del mundo contribución a la
mejora de los cultivos el desarrollo es
resultado de la colaboración de la
institución pública en la que trabaja
Raquel chang y de una empresa privada
vioceres la participación Estatal ha
sido clave la atención de fondos de
parte del Estado son absolutamente
necesarios porque los colaboradores o
los socios para etapas tardías del
desarrollo requieren que primero se
hayan cumplido
las etapas previas las pruebas de
concepto que demuestren que la inversión
que van a hacer va a tener sus frutos
Aunque de acuerdo en que el trigo hb4
Tiene un gran potencial Existen algunas
dudas puntuales entre ellas el hecho de
que en el proceso también se le otorgó
resistencia al glufosinato Pero Raquel
chang dice que no se utiliza el
herbicida y el año pasado se sembraron
55 mil hectáreas y este año un poco más
y en ningún caso sus óvulos porque no
sirve o sea para no es el mejor en
cualquier caso en el campo miran con
expectativas las pruebas con el serial
transgénico y mientras continúan los
procesos para su aprobación en varios
países se espera que el trigo hb4 salga
al mercado de entre 2023 y 2024